scott disick is ready to start dating
again after his split from amelia hamlin
yeah a source tells et quote scott is
interested in putting himself back out
there again and dating adding that he
has a hard time being alone and likes
having some sort of female companionship
whether it's serious or not as for
amelia et source says they are fully
done and she has no plans on going back
to him quote she feels like she saw his
true colors and realizes that he is not
what she wants
as for those true colors that seems to
be a reference to the social media snafu
that went down in the dms last month
when eunice benjamin who previously
dated scott's other ex kourtney
kardashian shared an alleged dm scott
sent him shading court's pda with her
current bow travis barker a source told
et at the time that quote scott was
trying to write the situation off as
nothing but as the days went by amelia
was more and more hurt by the whole
thing amelia and scott what stuff
[Music]
what the moment you're like what the
yeah she's 19. he's 37 with three kids
hello
i am a little nervous about it i'm a lot
nervous about it that was amelia's mom
lisa arena talking about the model's
relationship with scott during a june
episode of the real housewives of
beverly hills fast forward to the show's
finale and here's the update that was
shared in lisa's post-season wrap-up
quote lisa finally approves of amelia
and scott's relationship now that amelia
has called it quits great come on we do
a tv show it's a tv show last month
during an appearance on watch what
happens live with andy cohen the reality
star said she had no regrets about how
she reacted to her daughter dating the
38 year old you know i've actually been
quite nice about scott disick and i
would never say that out loud anything i
might have thought things
that weren't very good for yourself can
i atone for my thoughts okay yeah okay
so yeah you weren't i mean on the show
on broadcast television you weren't
totally thrilled about it
no but you weren't mean i doesn't mean
listen i tried really hard i was really
patient and i tried really hard we'll
leave it at that now as things get more
and more serious between courtney and
travis a source previously told et that
scott has quote unsettled ill will
towards them i'm not putting my energy
there at the time the source explained
quote courtney and scott are definitely
not as close as they once were scott has
some unsettled ill will towards courtney
and travis being together and courtney
is over the jealousy she thinks scott
needs to grow up
you